sweet words and wise words on this
morning welcome to the weekend everyone
i'm dana jacobson along with michelle
miller and jeff glor
we do have a bit of sad news this
morning as we wake up to the news of
congressman john lewis's passing
simply a legend in the battle for
equality and while it hurts the heart of
anyone who cares about equality
michelle we know you've met him many
times
indeed i have and each time was
memorable you always felt like you were
in the presence of greatness
kind strength mixed with oh that air of
humility
all his own and of course we begin with
that news
that came overnight congressman john
lewis of georgia
one of the leading figures of the 1960
civil rights era
has died he was 80 years old lewis was a
protege of the reverend dr martin luther
king jr
together they challenged the segregated
south lewis continued to fight for civil
rights throughout his career
and last december he revealed he had
stage four pancreatic cancer and said
he had never faced a battle like it
lewis told cbs this morning last month
he believed his health was improving ed
o'keefe shows how lewis was at the heart
of black america's struggle for equality
for more than six decades
we still have work to do congressman
john lewis was the youngest leader of
the civil rights movement
and it's enduring storyteller he helped
organize the march on washington in
august 1963
and his death means there is no longer
anyone alive who spoke
that day we do not want our freedom
gradually
but we want to be free now
two years later lewis led a march from
selma to montgomery alabama
a marching today from selma to
montgomery
we'll march into our state capitol to
dramatize to our nation and to the world
our determination to win first-class
citizenship that ended abruptly
at the bottom of the edmond pettis
bridge
immediately this is an unlawful assembly
you have to
disperse a day seared in the memories of
most americans
as bloody sunday i was the first person
to be hit
and i still have the scar on my forehead
and i was knocked down
my legs just went out from under me i
thought i was going to down this bridge
as a college student lewis led sit-ins
that helped desegregate nashville lunch
counters
he became a freedom rider risking his
life to force desegregation
he was there when lyndon johnson signed
the voting rights act
he was beaten spit at and over the
course of his life arrested more than 45
times all for what he called good
trouble i met rosa parks in 1957 when i
was 17
1958 i met dr king and these two
individuals inspired me to get in
trouble
and i've been getting in good trouble
necessarily
elected to congress from an atlanta
district in 1986
he was a liberal democrat who pushed for
civil rights gay rights
and boycotted two republican
presidential inaugurations
i was asked that all of my colleagues
joined me on the floor
days after a mass shooting in 2016 lewis
led an unprecedented sit-in
on the floor of the house trying and
failing
to secure votes for gun control
legislation
throughout his life he remained a living
reminder of the legacy of the civil
rights movement
when people tell me nothing has changed
i just feel like saying come and walk in
my shoes
i will show you i would take you to
those places
on capitol hill lewis was one of the few
lawmakers left
universally admired on both sides of the
aisle
in part for simple moments like this one
last year at the height of the
impeachment fight lewis participated in
a bipartisan tribute
to retiring georgia senator johnny
isakson a republican
lewis ended his remarks with something
rarely seen in washington anymore
he crossed the house floor for a
handshake
and a hug between a democrat and a
republican
in june lewis visited black lives matter
plaza in washington
the civil rights icon stood on the spot
of the new mural and said that it sends
a mighty powerful
and strong message to the rest of the
world
ed o'keefe cbs news
washington